أعتقد أن هذا يشير إلى vosdok
وهي الكلمة الروسية للشرق
والتي تشير أم إلى أن هذه
المعدات العسكرية جاءت من
الأقسام الشرقية للجيش الروسي ،
ما كنت أقوله هذا
المظهر كدليل لا أريد أن
أريكم هذا كثيرًا  لكن هناك جثة
هناك جندي روسي
يرقد هناك ميتًا على هذا الجسر
ملقى هناك ميتًا على هذا الجسر
حيث
حاول عموده القيادة
وتم إحباطه
منذ بدء هذا الغزو هو
أنني كنت في الواقع رابضًا في أوكرانيا  أسفل
حقًا بقنبلة يدوية هناك ، لم
أر ذلك ، لذا دعنا نبتعد عن
هذه النظرة ، أعني أن لديك
الجيش الأوكراني
الذي اشتد قتاله من معركته
في شرق البلاد التي كانوا
يقاتلون الروس و  المتمردون المدعومون من
روسيا في تلك المنطقة لفترة طويلة
، ولذا فهم يعرفون ما
يفعلونه ، لقد تم
تعزيزهم بوصولكم تعرفون أه صواريخ ستينغر وصواريخ جافلين
المضادة للدبابات من الولايات
المتحدة.  الدول ومن دول
أخرى أيضًا في الغرب ، في الواقع ،
أعلنت السويد بالأمس فقط أنها كانت
ترسل السويد
معززة ، حيث كانت تقدم 5000
صاروخ مضاد للدبابات إلى هذا البلد
لمساعدة الأوكرانيين في الدفاع ضد
الغزو الروسي ، ولذا فهي
بمساعدة تلك الأسلحة  أنهم
تمكنوا حقًا من التسبب في
قدر كبير
من الألم للروس